we have some tragic news i'm i'm afraid
to share uh yeah later well not not uh
welcome news at all uh your leisure
bachmann who uh uh i didn't know well
personally but i was privileged to know
and i'm sure you have also i've known
that quite well yeah a few times i
fortunately i didn't get a chance to
really spend as much time with him on my
trips to moscow as i would like to at
titan
in the world of chess a centurion yeah
he did make it to a hundred
fantastic but uh said passed away today
sadly passed away today uh we uh our
condolences to uh to the family and yeah
he was he was an absolute giant of the
game he was one of the world's foremost
authorities on alcohol all things to do
with endgames composed studies uh he was
still he would still come to tournaments
in moscow even in his late 90s
he was a kind of a fixture just you know
sitting in in the analysis room and
talking about chess his eyesight was uh
failing towards the later years he
wasn't as active analyzing with players
and so on but yeah he was a he was a
gentleman and uh
as i said privilege to have known him
yeah for me i must say that i was kind
of raised on his five volume end game
manuals and he had a
a book uh i think it was tactical
tactics uh a book by averbach that was
very very popular in the united states
and i feel very sad for him something is
just
a slightly you know lighter reference
but you know the
he was such a household name uh in in
soviet union and russia that he actually
made it into a pop song at one point
because
he used to have uh he used to have a
weekly i think a weekly uh tv show
called chess school with yuri averbach
and there was a pop song when i was a
kid which made reference to that tv show
and
everybody knew what he was talking about
the the
the singer like he was he was definitely
enough of a household name to to do for
for that show to be included in
pop culture
outstanding extraordinary uh and again
our condolences to his family you will
be
missed and i believe the only
international grand master
ever to become a centurion
lillian tall was rather close i mean
victor corchanoy was long-lived but not
even in his 90s so
a loss uh alejandro
yeah i think that every chess player has
grown up on averbach games and our back
studies and we've known of the upper
back variations and he's just
you can't state his contribution to
chess enough not only from a playing
perspective but i believe he was also
heavily involved in russian chess i
believe he was the head of the president
or the chairman of something of the
soviet chess for
i mean better part of five or six years
in the 70s
he definitely was uh was very very much
involved and uh yeah all aspects of
chess and
was also from all from all accounts an
extremely extremely nice person yeah not
not a good day today not a good day